hey youtubers is Charlie and tonight
during the big Marvel special we got our
first look at starlit Witch and
Quicksilver at least what they're gonna
look like in the movie it was all
concept art but we also got look at some
Hulkbuster armor which kind of informs
with a plot of Avengers 2 is going to be
just a little bit the whole thing was
just a deep dive into their creative
process and Marvel Studios behind the
scenes behind all these big movies that
make up the cinematic universe so I'm
mostly going to focus on the new stuff
you know the Avengers 2 and the
guardians of the galaxy stuff but I'll
also talk about some of the fun facts
that I thought were really interesting
if you finding me for the first time I
typically do Marvel movie videos every
Tuesday be sure to subscribe to get
everything and feel free to suggest a
future video in the comments so I'm just
gonna start with the really important
stuff first then work my way through
Avengers 2 and guardians of the galaxy
ant-man phase 3 and then talk about some
fun facts so here we go let's start with
the children of he-who-must-not-be-named
because of copyright I'm talking about
Quicksilver and Scarlet which of course
they haven't started principal
photography on their scenes yet and most
of the footage we've seen from
Johannesburg was all second unit stuff
so all of this was concept art but it
really is what they'll actually look
like it's just the plainclothes
millennial version of their characters
maybe during the course of the film
they'll get official Avengers of
costumes like Captain America got in
that first movie I won't talk about it
in this video but there actually is a
scene with those two characters that
you'll be able to see really soon I have
spoilers for it in my Avengers 2 video I
posted last week I'll have a link to
that at the end of this video if you
want to see it but now let's talk about
some Hulkbuster armor it's a slightly
modified and coloured version of the
armor we saw during Iron Man 3 meaning
he's rebuilt some of his armory and the
Hulk is going to be a huge problem in
Avengers 2 in the comics there's this
really notable story called world war
hulk
it takes place directly after the Planet
Hulk storyline Hulk just comes back to
earth and beats the crap out of every
single superhero he can see a lot of
people including myself thought that
they would do a storyline like this at
some point especially in a standalone
hook film we didn't really think it
would happen this soon though it's gonna
be a lot of fun though in that first
film he really didn't collide with the
team too much in the sequel it seems
like Mark Ruffalo is going to be
smashing a lot more stuff you know
spending much more time in character as
the whole
sidenote to the Red Hulk was also a huge
part of the age of Ultron comic book
story that story won't be what this film
is about this is actually gonna be more
about the Mighty Avengers Ultron
initiative storyline but I really do
think that everyone wants that
standalone Mark Ruffalo Hulk film at
some point hopefully soon just speaking
about one of the most important
characters though Ultron he was not
present nor was James Spader
though here's some details about the
actual story of the movie the larger
story is mostly going to be inspired by
Mighty Avengers Ultron initiative that's
where Ultron takes over the armor of
Tony Stark it came after the Civil War
storyline you can actually read the
comic books if you want to learn more
about that so let's move on to Phase
three for a second before we talk about
some fun to vengers facts
Feige actually repeated some of his
earlier comments about changing the
Avengers roster mostly referring to
Quicksilver and Scarlet Witch in
Avengers 2 but they also played the
ant-man test footage over the credits
it's just the old test footage that
Edgar Wright played at Comic Con a long
time ago but in my ant-man preview this
morning I actually predicted that he
would become part of the Avengers during
the third movie Avengers 3 it's not
rocket science
Scott Lang actually became an Avenger in
the comic books that really raises the
question though who are they going to
cycle out of the Avengers is there going
to be cycling people in right now Robert
Downey jr. last movie is Avengers 3 he's
gonna be the first man out probably
after that unless he takes a major
pinkett they'll be forced to either cut
him out the character out or recast the
part of Iron Man moving on in phase 3
though it's pretty obvious that they're
pushing towards the collection of the
infinity gems to reform the gauntlet
it's a little too early to do any
Avengers 3 videos but feel free to ask
me anything about how all this stuff
fits together with the Infinity garland
in the comics it'll largely be shield
and guardians of the galaxy that will be
the connective tissue between the cosmic
elements of the films and the
earth-based films so eventually we're
gonna get a diner scene with Agent
Coulson and star-lord at some point in
one of these movies so here's a couple
Marvel and Avengers facts that I thought
were really cool that we learned during
the special some were just really funny
starting things off whenever they first
got started with Iron Man almost every
single writer in Hollywood that they
offered the project to turned it down
number two the only reason they were
able to obtain financing for the first
couple of films was by bundling them
together in what would eventually be
known as the Marvel Cinematic Universe
so it wasn't just a genius creative
decision they actually did it for
financial reasons - that was the only
way the bank would buy into it three
during the first Iron Man after Gwyneth
Paltrow signed on to the project and
came in to meet with Favreau and Robert
Downey jr. for the first time they all
ended up crying in a weepy mess just
because they were so happy that
everything was working out it was a huge
gamble for samuel l.jackson actually won
the part of Nick Fury in that same Iron
Man film because his agent cold called
Kevin Feige and they just loved the idea
so much five the tesseract became the
first big MacGuffin that's the thing
that drives the plot forward with very
little you know if no explanation in
phase two it's going to be the infinity
gems and in Phase three it'll be the
Infinity Gauntlet and last one number
six a nice George R Martin clip turns
out the Avengers were what made him fall
in love with comics as a child he
actually did a podcast with Nerdist and
Chris Hardwick about going to the first
ever comic book convention in the world
in New York I'll actually post a link to
that in the description below so we saw
a whole bunch of awesome new stuff you
know including some very awesome teasers
for some of the future films let me know
what you're most excited to see
guardians is really only a couple months
away and we might get to the point where
Marvel is actually releasing four films
a year so let me know which films would
you like to see them do next at least
that is in phase 4 after Avengers 3 I
know we're totally all thinking the same
thing we want a Deadpool movie so right
now click here for my ant-man preview
and click here for my Avengers 2 preview
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you guys tonight
high fives